catherine two things
bravo on whatever was going on in there
it is not it is whatever your heart
desires and none of my business
i will let the fates play their hand
second
i think you best come to the stateroom
with me the lunch seems to not sit well
in some people's stomachs
what do they want i don't know anytime
one of them talks the others start
yelling
i made them put their pistols in a
bucket it's times like these i'm so glad
you are my key military strategist tread
lightly my dear we will be here if you
need us
gentlemen
[Applause]
do you have a representative
empress everest forgive the mob we're
here to object to your plans to free the
surf
well there's been a misunderstanding
then lying german [ __ ]
break this country
we have no concrete plans only an
innocent jape that i hope you all
enjoyed so you are telling us you have
not thought any further than that indeed
you haven't written down say a 109 page
master plan
oddly specific but no would you mind
explaining these documents all those
given us
they forced it out at me at gunpoint
you set me up nothing personal
actually that's probably a tiny bit
untrue
a moment gentlemen
are you all right you seem a little red
i feel a little red ah
everyone wants to kick me right now
ponder that later act on this now
you must explain that this is another of
your experiments
barely sketched out and open to change
forgive them their panic
for it seems you wish to unpick the
basis of everything they know
you don't
[Music]
if you could be quiet i would like to
explain if you expect them to work for
us then someone's going to have to pay
them labor costs the impact of which no
one knows other than to make our exports
uncompetitive the church will crush us
on coal we would figure all that out
if we open our minds to it i know we
have the solution in this very room we
will be at the whim of those inbreds
[Music]
who have rights
who are human souls with much to give oh
we run their life
feed owls instruct them care for them
anything they want to do all of that for
themselves and in their downtime
contribute ideas of genius to russia no
offense but it does sound like
madness when you add it all up
gentlemen
these papers these ones
[Applause]
give us your word this will never happen
empress and we will of course go back to
honoring and supporting you
gently
gentlemen
listen or i'll
shoot you all
i understand what you have read this
evening seems alarming
and upon reflection
you are probably right
i have been a lying german [ __ ]
because i will be freeing the serves
today
and yes i yelled that bit for effect and
yes you will pay them a wage and they
will buy goods and services and create
another economy and they will strive for
more and invest themselves in russia and
the filthy stain of serfdom will be off
your hearts and unfortunately you may
actually end up richer but i actually
don't care whether it costs you it will
be done and there's no amount of threat
or spittle that you can aim at me that
will change my mind on that get used to
the future gentlemen
because it's coming
who threw that
oh god why are they throwing shoes
they hate you and i took their guns
[Applause]
[Music]